[Musique]
c'est ce qu'on appelle une erreur de
communication en tout cas c'est ce
qu'estime certains qui sur les raisons
critiqué le message porté par la marque
evian
hier la marque d'eau a postés sur les
réseaux sociaux un message pour inciter
les internautes à boire retweeter si
vous avez déjà vu un livre aujourd'hui
un message plutôt anodin sauf qu' elle
est aussi la journée mondiale du ramadan
période d'un mois durant laquelle les
musulmans ne peut pas manger ou boire
avant le coucher du soleil
immédiatement certains internautes se
sont offusqués d'une telle communication
regretter ce message certes insinuant
même que cela pourrait être une
provocation de la part de la filiale de
danone
pourquoi aujourd'hui spécifiquement ces
vicieux quand même pas ta ce bad buzz la
marque a décidé de répondre en
s'excusant
bonsoir ici la team evian désolé pour la
maladresse de ce tweet qui n'appelle à
aucune provocation des excuses que
beaucoup ne comprennent pas pour eux il
était normal que soit la religion qui
dicte sa loi
même sur les réseaux alors plus
polémique evian at elle bien fait de
s'excuser
merci fayzabad mohamed d'être avec nos
journaliste et militante merci d'être là
faiza et merci eric naulleau bien sûr
qu'on ne présente plus voilà qui est
souvent avec nous et il sera de retour
avec moi dans btp la saison prochaine
bien entendu avec plaisir un eric voilà
sur battles seule annonce intéressante
voilà comme ça voilà c'est que daf un
petit billet qui vient de tomber
toujours du bien dormir est bien appuyé
ce message sur son compte twitter
retweete si vous avez déjà bu un litre
d'evian aujourd'hui hier c'était le
début du ramadan alors pays'' a déjà
vous est ce que vous vous comprenez les
gens qui n'ont pas aimé ce tweet d'evian
mais qui sont ces gens qui n'ont pas
aimé ce tweet d'evian en fait c'est ça
la question qu'il faut poser à votre
question de savoir est ce que evian a
bien fait de s'excuser
cet evian n'a pas publié uniquement des
excuses ils ont clarifié le twitch
initial mais après sur la question de
dire puisque ça le débat des musulmans
qui ont qui sont pas d'accord parce que
en premier le premier jour du ramadan
ils ont besoin comme une progr
provocation oui moi je les ai vus ces
twitts il m'a pas choqué j'ai pas eu
plus soif par ce que j'ai vu ce tweet
d'accord j'ai pas pu souffert du ramadan
parce que evian a posté ça et même quand
on cherche les réactions à 7,8
on trouve pas tant de réactions que
c'est pourquoi evian a pris peur et il
vient
ils se sont excusés ils ont ces
incroyables eric naulleau moi je suis
chez moi j'ai cru que c'était un poisson
d'avril
vraiment j'ai j ai pas cru et pourtant
c'est une vraie polémique
non evian a commis une grosse erreur une
seule grosse erreur c'est de s'excuser
il n'avait pas à s'excuser il ont fait
leur travail le boulot déviance et de
vendre de l'evian sans se préoccuper du
calendrier musulman du calendrier
chrétien du calendrier bouddhistes et
même du calendrier at et le problème
c'est que dans les détracteurs derrière
moi je pense que 99% vers une 9 % des
musulmans s'en foutent mais il ya une
petite minorité active qui est une
minorité islamistes et qui profitent de
chaque occasion même des occasions aussi
bizarre que ça pour essayer de faire
avancer la cause islamiste à dire de
faire de deux mètres la loi islamiste au
dessus de la loi de la république donc
ce sont des activistes qui provoque ces
petits l'agitation de résoudre vite
regardez pas ce qu'il ya de iasi
leverdez et guillaume genton qui eux
pensent qu'elle vient on a bien fait de
s'excuser pourquoi gilles ce café evian
c'est scandaleux moi je vais vous dire
lequel le premier tweet premier tweet
certification d'evian pour moi je vous
croyais à un mot fort c'est de
l'islamophobie commercial c'est-à-dire
que vous faites exprès de taper de
provoquer de taper sur les musulmans
vous ils ont fait ça si elles savent
très bien c'est sciemment et ils se
foutent du bad buzz parce que c'est du
buzz
donc il se dit on y va à bout monta
premier jour du ramadan faut pas les
prendre pour des gens stupides et bien
c'est danone c'est un grand groupe ils
savent très bien ce qu'ils font ils
tapent sur les musulmans et il voit que
ça suscite une polémique dont qui
s'excuse y sont obligé de s'excuser mais
c'est scandaleux de faire ça c'est pas
du tout et cela miser sur le ramadan
vous on le tombé des nues et c'est
dramatique ce que tu me l'annoncer à
cause des propos comme ça qu'on combat
une foule immense et on ne fait plus
créer une scission encourager les noms
oui oui c'est pas moi c'est non non je
crois pas d'une ampleur mec j'ai bien à
la pub qui dit on va faire une pub pour
bora les dodos par jour parce que c'est
le lot de produire du ramadan c'est un
peu c'est vous rigolez
géraldine maillet et gilles verdez
pardon mais je trouve que tu es fou
furieux et était vraiment un danger
public
mais ça fait une polémique enfle a fait
une polémique la génération aujourd'hui
des offenses et des indignés qui tombe
dans le sort de tourbillon comme ça a
dit que si mr c'est dramatique donc
juste je vais te dire sur france 5 à
midi on nous apprenait à faire une soupe
de maïs provoque islamophobie hockey à
12h15 y avait une pub pour la publicité
une publicité pardon pour la compote de
fruits est ce que c'est de la provoc
aujourd'hui sur m6 ça n'a rien à voir il
faudra s'agit bien des tyrans mais là
non là c'est de la publicité classique
là comme par hasard vous avez déjà
buralistes le déjà si vous avez déjà
loupé ce que font aujourd'hui arrêter
ses volontés très grave eric naulleau
parce que d'abord il se comporte en
idiot utile de l'islamisme non méritants
mais non j'ai pas mon nom est la balle
en jeu m avec une fine en fait tous les
jours des tweets y voient même pas si je
finis thermale il relève le tweet
aujourd'hui mais tous les jours moi
qu'est une maison à evian je peux vous
dire que tous les ans d'après un train
tous les jours une petite elle allonge
ya des trucs sur les eaux thermales et
que les votes ont annoncé des vers days
aggrave le sentiment de persécution des
musulmans pour un motif en plus
imaginaires c'est déjà assez tendue en
ce moment il ya des polémiques régulière
il ya parfois des polémiques sur des
bases réelles
là c'est une base complètement
imaginaire et il ya des gens qui vont
prendre au sérieux sur une
responsabilité et tu sors des énormités
pareilles n'est pas une généralité
concours à la discorde nationale et même
d'un jour à la guerre civile je ne
raconte pas n'importe quoi essaye
d'utiliser des arguments pour puisse
croire là je crois même pas ce que tu
dis je crois pas que toi tu crois que tu
une série longue de l'eau sur le plateau
on donne de l'eau serait voilà un défaut
par ailleurs qui font le ramadan est ce
que c'est une provocation
est ce que ces résistants maintenant et
juillan evian et bien c'est une marque
d'eau gilles donc c'est tout à fait
normal qu'ils communiquent sur l'eau
donc tu va nous dire que pendant toute
la durée du ramadan
cette marque qui vend en l'occurrence de
l'eau n'a plus le droit de communiquer
en laroque toutes les marques qui font
de l'alimentaire le soir et ben voilà
donc en fait y'a plus de publicité le
soir
ce cas ainsi qu'à chaque fois mon
sourire qu'on a ça 3h16 de l'après midi
si vous avez déjà bu 1er janvier vous
êtes doté sache mais je suis désolé mais
c'est un show plein de gens parce que
c'est fait pour choquer vous êtes des
secours est minoritaire
kidioui que est bien bien fait et que tu
décès guillaume genton moi je suis pas
daccord exil je trouve pas ça
islamophobes en revanche c'est une
grosse erreur de communication evian
c'est une entreprise nationale
internationale s'est consommé dans le
monde entier il ya des millions de
français qui font le ramadan
oui c'est très maladroit de dire à 3h16
en pleine journée si vous avez déjà bu
un litre d'eau aujourd'hui il aurait pu
trouver autre chose quoi c'est pas la
photo on n'a pas à mettre de l'argent
dans la consommation manager je suis
désolé les mecs qui pourraient réfléchir
deux secondes
il ya des millions de personnes qui
boivent pas d'eau pendant la journée il
pourrait s'abstenir de posté ce tweet
c'est au sortir de l'été pour le temps
tu te rends compte franchement les
normes
ça veut dire qu'on va devoir maintenant
oui en compte du calendrier religieux et
oui 10 km et enfin alors et c'est le
sport a un gros et beaucoup de com de la
part des vivants parce qu'on n'a jamais
autant parlé des viols à fizi sweet
en plus c'était un tweet quasiment
quotidiens qu'ils font mais c'est le mag
ils vont pas arrêter de communiquer le
jour du ramadan parce que tout d'un coup
c'est normal on pas ce qu'ils vont faire
ça pour toutes les fêtes et puis alors
demain on va voir ça sur tous les
produits sur toutes les campagnes télé
vagin vous êtes devenu du coup moi je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec tous mes
camarades c'est toute cette histoire
toute cette histoire est idiote c'est à
dire moi mon grand père il est mort à
peu dans la seconde guerre mondiale et
j'ai pas regardé la 7ème compagnie quoi
je veux dire c'est exactement du même
acabit c'est complètement fou voilà je
pense que c'est notre meilleure attaque
ça fait partie du top 3 en tout cas
c'est sûr et certain
et ça va chéri et moi je sais exactement
ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure je
suis bien placé pour savoir qui
communique tout le temps tous les jours
sauf que là on le relève à ce moment-là
et du coup ça devient un truc
islamophobe et je suis entièrement
d'accord qu'on a déjà du mal à vivre
tous ensemble calmement c'est pas la
peine de faire de la provocation
imbécile alors qu'il faut au contraire
tous être unis
c'est dramatique il faut arrêter de
diviser tout le monde avec des conneries
rien là dedans de mal je devais me dire
que le groupe danone qui est également
propriétaire de badoit ils ont fait un
truc super je voulais souligner de
badoit se mobilisent pour soutenir bars
des restaurants du 1er avril au 15 mai
pour tout achat d'une badoit 1% des
ventes sera reversée à 5 bars et
restaurants mais oui c'est la chemise
lui sur ce qu'ils ont bien fait de
s'excuser pour vous c'est pas des
excuses qui sont formulées ils ont clamé
pension oui mais après moi je suis
franchement je suis vraiment fasciné par
la tournure de ce débat en fait on part
du postulat que les musulmans ce sont
eux se sont insurgés on avait qu'on soit
clair laissez moi juste terminée j'ai
écouté je vous demande juste deux
minutes on est très clair si vous
épluchez concrètement tous les tweets
qui a eu en dessous vous en avez 99% qui
émane de l'extrême droite pourquoi parce
que quand enfin il faut un moment donné
c'est poser la question deux pour quelle
raison est ce que hier soir damien rieu
membre très actif de génération
identitaire était déjà en live sur
télégramme pour parler de cette
polémique pour quelles raisons est ce
que quand on analyse les outils twitter
pour savoir qu'elle ne compte on
contribué à propulser cette polémique en
top tweets quand on s'inquiète à son
tour des mesures
monsieur goldnadel avocat de génération
identitaire damien rieu identitaire
connu et reconnu
or habitants grande gueule de elle aussi
connu pour pour des
un débat c'est pas ça le débat saision
vous remettez pas en question d'oubli
trouvez moi un musulman avec un nom
prénom qui sent pas un fake est où 1 1
et je m'excuse s'est séparé avec des
excuses est ce que j'aimais est-ce que
vous pouvez nier que le fait que ayant
s'excuse et bien la preuve qu'il ya un
climat qu'on n'a jamais connu auparavant
et que sur ce plateau on trouve quand
même deux personnes pour soutenir une
thèse aussi délirante que evian l'aurait
fait exprès le premier jour du ramadan
je trouve ça très en effet pas à quelque
chose dans les têtes de très inquiétant
mais c'est le lot que je vous pose la
question trouvez nous s'il vous plaît un
musulman avec un nom un prénom
identifiés sur les réseaux sociaux
qu'ils puissent venir témoigner ça vous
savez aujourd'hui j'ai été contacté même
pas seulement par tpm paix par
énormément de d'autres rédactions qui me
disaient voilà est-ce que vous pouvez
venir bah en fait en gros endosser cette
position de dire voilà je vous avez bien
fait de le préciser votre moule pourquoi
vous êtes là ce soir oui j'ai juste les
gens il a pourquoi elle est là besoin
c'est qu'elle dit que cette polémique
pour elle elle a été créée par des gens
que evian ont été instrumentalisés et
qu'il ya pas de mu mots qui se sont
insurgés contre cette pub que c'est
c'est eh mais voilà il se serait quant à
lui en a certains qui est très technique
à recife elsa nous disait jeu et viande
n'aurait n'avait pas à s'excuser vision
n'aurait pas dû se séparer ils ont
clarifié et caen et quand vous êtes et
vous les êtes bien placé pour le savoir
et moi aussi quand on est harcelé sur
les réseaux sociaux parfois on est
obligé de faire un deuxième tweet pour
que ça cesse pour que ça s'arrête pour
que les gens comprennent que en 140
caractères des fois on n'a pas de quoi
expliquer en grand pompe est bon
maintenant après la question qui se pose
à moi je pense qu'ils n'auraient pas dû
réagir ben oui je le dis je ne vois que
les fiancés monde au préfet rien
j'aurais gêné c'est vrai parce que c'est
la seule qui a un ph neutre
oui et pour ma peau pour mon épiderme
c'est magnifique j'aime pas trop ce que
dit eric parce que vous sous-entendez
que ce que je dis ou mon attitude est
une provocation je le jugerai le à dire
oui mais les rires oui mais excusez moi
une seconde vous retournez le débat le
vrai débat c'est une provocation qui
vient
evian et vous nous accusez nous vous
matrisez mois et guillaume d'endosser
ses convocations mais pas du tout moi je
vous regarde
mais oui mais laissez moi finir j'ai été
choqué et heureusement qu'evian s'excuse
parce que cette rage une vocation il
s'excuse c'est tragique c'est oui toutes
les communes et religieuse à ce moment
là pour on l'exigé
mais oui et ne me traitez pas
d'islamiste ça vous pouvez pas vous
retirer ça vous êtes un idiot utile de
10,91 c'est un mec qui faisions là voilà
vous êtes un allié objectif de
l'histoire fait un examen de conscience
non non non je te vous dites est
irresponsable
alors on va voir ce qu'on pensait
téléspectateurs tiens ça s'arrête
intéressant oui à 10% non 8%
c'était incroyable c'est rare que le
sondage soit aussi tranchée c'est vrai
que cfoot ont-ils verde ce qu'est ce que
vous répondez à ça mais je savais que ma
position était minoritaire mais si vous
adoptez forcément des positions qui sont
contre vos comics vous contre vos
convictions pour toucher la majorité
c'est pas bien on est comme ça c'est la
position je suis choqué je le disais je
sais que suis minoritaire mais je vois
là c'est ma vie et je n'en mets juste à
temps des personnes ne peut y voir un
super coup comme déviants et non mais
c'est le balance quotidiennement après
c'est pas des excuses des plates excuses
c'est juste coucou les teams machin
regarder bonsoir ici à steam et bien
désolé pour la maladresse de ce tweet
qui n'appelle aucune provocation
non je n'en sais rien est-ce que vous
pensez que ça va avoir une incidence sur
evian de sérieuses rien du tout moi je
pense que je connais bien showbiz et de
bien sûr bien sûr en temps réel la
cristalline et bien sûr exquise à saper
desriaux